Speaker 1: Urine therapy, urine? Yes. Urine,
the bodily fluid urine. Christopher Keys,
who is another one of these COVID conspiracists,
he's an anti-vax leader of sorts. He is now urging
followers to drink their own urine to fight COVID.
Let's take a look at the clip. This is quite vile
and also incredibly stupid. Take a look at this.
Speaker 3: The antidote that we've seen now and we
have tons and tons of research is urine therapy.
Speaker 1: That's right, folks,
you are not. Don't adjust your television.
He is saying urine. You are I and E..
Speaker 3: Oh, OK. And I know a lot of you,
a lot of you. This sounds crazy, right? But
guys, God's given us everything we need.
OK. And I'm going to give you again. I test and
prove all things OK. This has been around for
centuries, and we've got research after research,
documented peer review, published papers on urine.
Speaker 1: Now it is true that there are peer
reviewed, published papers about urine. It's
not about urine curing COVID. Now, understand that
there's a back story to this. There's a back story
to all of these ideas. There's like a recycling
of old ideas going on. Urine has been promoted in
the past for treating cancer. Cancer Society says
there's no evidence of therapeutic use of urine.
People talk about irrigating your sinuses with
a neti pot. Some people use distilled, filtered
water for the neti pot. There's the idea of
using urine, running urine through your sinuses,
brushing your teeth with urine. That's an
interesting one. Applying urine directly to
the skin for some kind of skin treatment. The
source of all of this is a simple idea that
there are certain tumor proteins present in the
urine of cancer patients, and the idea came from.
If you introduce urine into the body in different
ways, then the body will start to make antibodies
against the tumor proteins, and it might destroy
the cancer or have other benefits. It's all bogus.
It's true that urine can contain tumor antigens.
There is no evidence that shows that drinking it,
using it for massages, using it to bake a cake,
bathing in it or any other urine applications
actually does any of the things that it's claimed
to do. Now I want to be thorough here when we talk
about urine. We need to be thorough. There is one
possible bridge use of urine for health purposes.
OK, now does anybody know what it is? If you are
completely dehydrated and without water and you're
on the verge of dying, urine is 95 percent water.
There is some belief that for the very short term,
you might be able to survive in a at a point of
catastrophic dehydration by drinking your urine
for a day or maybe two. OK. Urine in a general
sense, it's 95 percent water. It's safe to drink.
It will replenish some lost water. The problem is
that that other five percent, that's not water,
isn't stuff you want a lot of in your body.
You're basically taking the stuff your kidneys
have filtered out and you're putting it back
in and it'll end up back in your kidneys and
you can end up with really, really bad symptoms
from long term drinking of urine. But if you're
in a completely desperate situation,
no water, you're close to death. It's
conceivable that drinking your own urine might
let you survive just a little bit until you get
rescued or whatever. There's actually the book
437 days about the fisherman. Salvador Alvarenga,
who drifted offshore in Mexico, ended up in
the Pacific islands. At some brief periods. He
drank his own urine, but he very quickly figured
out how to collect rainwater. He would not have
been able to survive just drinking urine for four
hundred and thirty seven days. So that's the truth
about so-called urine therapy. Christopher
Keys, dangerous conspiracist not to be followed.